what's up everyone welcome back to the
cinema center at marble at Tiff 2023 for
another interview I am lucky enough to
be sitting with the team behind irena's
vow huge huge huge congratulations on
your film you've got lots to look
forward to when you head over to your
Premiere after this thank you very much
for a little all feeling a little
overwhelmed I think I feel like that's
the good kind of overwhelming though and
it's gonna gonna pay off I got very high
hopes so a lot of our audience does not
know about your movie just yet Louise
I'm going to ask you to do this I'm sure
you're going to be doing this quite a
bit during the festival but can you give
us a brief synopsis of the film for
people who don't know about it just yet
well even as well it's about that woman
Irena good uh who's a who was a Polish
Catholic woman uh was turning to be a
nurse actually but at some point during
the war the beginning of the war she was
forced labored and uh and she started to
work as uh how do you say that gunferner
and we are not made
um foreign
character and
at some point she did risk her life to
save the lives of some Jews and she did
hit them in the Villa Enriquez Villa so
this is a true story it's the story
about her courage but mostly about just
she she was a giver so she wanted to
help the others whatever religion
whatever the culture whatever who you
are we're from you know just like help
one another another and there's it's a
film about love for sure and hope
spot-on description right there spot on
description but I will say until you're
fully immersed in the story you don't
get that kind of overwhelming sense of
emotion it's really something else I
wanted to ask you about something that I
read in our press notes that Dan had
said because Dan brought it to uh the
stage then of course the adapted it and
he mentioned the story is so much more
relevant today than it was 10 years ago
when he first wrote the play so of
course it is based on a true story but
is there anything the two of you wanted
to evolve or bring out and focus on in
the film more because of the increased
relevancy
um I think it's it's all there you know
even a story it's it's relevant but what
we did experience and actually Dan
Gordon was uh did visit the shoot the
first days of the shoot and we were
shooting in Lublin that's just the next
next door to Ukraine border and at some
point day two of shooting we were
shooting that it's a difficult scene
with a scaffolder and so we had stunts
to rehearse that that scene and at some
point we we did shoot that scene but we
had to put signs all over the place for
people walking by because in in Polish
in English and in Ukrainian because at
that point so many uh Kernan refugees
they are they were and are in that town
and to to see uh they were exposed to to
a scene that's quite violent that
occurred more than 50 years ago but it's
still it still happens today in various
ways and so reality meets fiction in
that sense in that way and and actually
done after one take he came out and he
cried so much and what he saw Sophie and
he was like he she looks so much like
Irena because the last 10 years of
irana's life there were friends so there
was something that yeah at some point
that story still needs to be told the
increased relevancy is the most
heartbreaking thing in the world to me
it's just like I don't understand how we
don't learn given how challenging this
material is so if fee what would you set
like also because you've had your fair
share of very challenging material
recently what is the key to being able
to access a headspace in a scenario like
that but also I guess kind of protect
yourself and know that you could pull
out of it yeah
um I don't know kind of this it's just
always come really natural to me I'm
able to tap out of it
weirdly very easily give me your secrets
for like my day-to-day life please yeah
I actually have a harder time in my
daily life to like get rid of anxiety
that's more the issue actually
um but I don't know on set I just I'm so
playful all the time I like to joke
around I like to keep it light
um obviously it was very easy to tap
into the heavy material because we were
surrounded and by all this Decor by the
sets by
um you know the Holocaust
symbols the swastikas and everything
um and so we felt completely immersed
and so it was very easy for me to tap
into the gravity of it all and to just
feel scared and
um just terrified and sad all these
emotions but I don't know for some
reason as soon as she calls cut I'm like
thinking about what I'm gonna eat for
lunch quite literally sometimes even
during the scene so it's never really
been a problem for me to keep it light
most most impressive I feel like when
you're doing something with maximum
passion like that it might be like I can
sit here and talk like a normal human
being but if we walk over there after
and I start talking I'll speak gibberish
and I think it makes sense right after a
crying scene I'm I'm over the crying
scene already most impressive all right
now I'm gonna make uh the two of you
make Sophie blush right now because I'm
a big believer that you need to lead
more projects in the future so what is
something about her as a scene partner
and as a as a lead actor that you really
appreciated and you're looking forward
to more actors and directors to
experience when they work with her in
the future
very centered around me and I don't like
this I can't help it well I thought that
you know she she says a lot how she's
not a method and how she's not really
thinking about she just sort of does it
somehow that she can't really connect
she feels that she can't connect but
from the outside it's it doesn't look
like that she looks very involved she's
got a very instinctive way to approach
acting and as an actor working with her
I I feel that you know she goes with it
she's alive to what's happening in the
scene and you know she's she reacts to
what you're doing and I react to her and
so she's able to I think sort of play a
little bit like jazz and in that sense
which I really really like she's also
great fun yes she does talk gibberish
when she's finished the scene but it
makes me laugh
and then similarly when we're having
dinner in the evening it's just because
the subject matter is so heavy you need
someone who just
who who really kind of roast you for
about an hour and a half which is what
she did regularly did to me so you never
get carried away with you know anything
not that I do but she certainly brings
you back down to earth if you need it to
be brought back down to earth you know
there's there are many things two main
things she's very smart and sensitive
and actually I did you know uh I got
some proposition from other actors
well-known actors I met them through
Zoom because it was pandemic and I did
suggest Sophie to the producers they're
like oh yeah and then I met Sophie she
was uh actually she was shooting at the
first season of yellow jacket you know
remember and I think we talked for uh
and I knew Sophie from before but and we
talked for let's say an hour and a half
and never Sophie did talk about herself
during that time that moment you know
she talked about hirena she talked about
the war she talked about well you talked
about your your step grandfather who was
like in a concentration camp at some
point in Chile but we talked about
human relationships and and you know how
can we be generous uh and how can we
have a better world we talked about that
a lot and at the end of the our
conversation I was like it was so
obvious she was the one you know she was
the one she has that inside her so to to
to to personify this character Sophie
has that inside her you know she's
generous she's she she cares about
others you know and she's curious and so
she would be curious she's curious about
characters and the story but she was his
careers with her Partners as well and
working Partners so they have the green
and so if he had that they they were
interested in one another so when you're
acting and you're listening really
listening to your partner in front of
you is they're better actors they're
just more generous and they let go their
ego to be there in that in the scene
they they they become they become the
characters they become the story you
know so they did that both of them are
like questions yeah that's like a primer
for what you can expect when you see
that audience after the movie screens
for for both of you this movie does
cover a considerable amount of their
experience but you only have one feature
film to get them to feel like full
living breathing characters with a
history where all of their motivation is
Justified so for each of you what is
something about them that isn't
necessarily like seen on screen or said
but you knew was important to making
them whole and now we could feel it
informing your performance
well he was an engineer and he was a a
pragmatist and he wanted everything to
run incredibly smoothly and I think that
you could draw a parallel between his uh
position as a manager of a musicians
Factory and what was happening during
the Holocaust and the sort of the
smoother with smoothness with which he
wanted his fight too to run and the kind
of
you know the the the the the genocide
that was happening concurrently and it
was happening so uh apparently and just
um you know
it was just so horrendous what was
happening and yet they all wanted us to
to to to be almost like uh machine-like
um like a factory and I think that he he
wanted to find some sort of comfort
within his relationship with Irina uh
when he met her because she represented
innocence and uh some sort of light and
amongst the the darkness and not that he
ever suddenly materialized them to being
a good person and a good man but he
allowed things to happen that were you
know the the the that caused lives to be
saved as it were when he discovered that
she was hiding Jews within his Cellar of
his house so I think that the
inspiration that he found within Arena's
character had an effect on on life on
the Universe on the light because
uh you know I think good will prevail
over evil ultimately and she was an
inspiration for that she was a catalyst
for that she was the uh the the colonel
if you like of that whole movement of
good that happened within these
horrendous set of circumstances that
occurred this genocide these mass
murders that occurred so I think the
surprising thing for me about him was
his
his desire his yearning to you know lead
a simple life within this uh this horror
this chamber of Horrors have that for
you now Sophie that's a good question
um I think we never get to talk about
her family much in this story which it's
which she's
um lost right before the war
um and
I think they're a huge driving force for
her
um I know that my family if I can
compare is what grounds me and is what
keeps me going and are the people
um who I have unlimited trust and love
and so I think
um in we rarely see her alone but I
think in those moments of solitude
um she has them with her and she
um they're they're the ones carrying her
somewhat through this and then in the
hopes of of finding them again and of
being there for her and um I think also
coming again from a pretty big family
that she had numerous sisters
um I think it does give you this sense
of community and altruism and the sense
of being there for one another and
selflessness and I think that's what you
see in her
um when she meets I mean the group of of
people that are working for Romero she
wants to
she sees them as her peers as her family
immediately as people that she would do
anything to save
um and so yeah it comes through quite
strongly especially paired with when
those references are made at the
beginning middle and end of the film I
found that very effective so you two are
at the center of this movie but you also
have a phenomenal supporting Ensemble
around you so to highlight some of them
now can you maybe give me one example of
a time when a scene partner was just the
person you needed to tackle a really
challenging scene and maybe helped you
access something in your own character
that you wouldn't have been able to
without them well the yeah I mean
they're all amazing actors
um and I think that uh Mitchell he was
an incredible
um
who played rokita sorry yeah he was the
uh you know uh he played a pretty dark
character and he commits one of the most
horrendous you know Acts yeah I think
I've ever seen in any film and
um there was a sort of a a
comfortability within him about what his
character was doing and I think that
made it quite uh horrendous and
horrifying to work with
um but he was trying to normalize what
was going on and I think uh that for me
working with him you know he had a great
sense of ease about what his character
was doing
that was that was pretty pretty
um good to work with something else in
that role yeah too good too good yeah
anyone for you Sophie well I think you
mentioned and he who played um yeah
um he was just
I mean he had such this calming presence
on set he was so
settled down in at peace with everything
and just talked so slow and for some
reason
you just hung and and clinged on to his
every single word because he was so
captivating and and playing with him was
just
watching a show unravel slowly in front
of you and it was you could just get
lost in his monologues and
yeah he really felt like a father's face
yeah it was just he felt like you
flipped inside of me yeah and it just
easily I just felt so emotional whenever
he would just look at me
um and he was like sort of this
grandfather uh figure for me
um yeah I loved his performance on this
all right all three of you anyone can
jump in on this one but when you make a
movie you could plan plan things aren't
going to go to according to plan every
single day so can you give me an example
of a time when something wasn't going
according to plan you had to find a
creative solution and you wound up
finding like unexpected magic that was
even better than what you had originally
planned hmm I mean
there was this one time uh before we
started shooting I come up to Louise and
we're testing some wigs out and I come
on set for the screen testing and she
looks at me and she goes
and we think I prefer the left side and
I was like
nope it wasn't a proposition it's just
really unequal hair it's just really I
don't know what happened with that
hairstyle it just yeah didn't make any
sense we had very short pre-productions
yeah this film and it's a period piece
yeah based on a true story and was like
yeah a little many things like that was
getting the hair I had like I mean I had
highlights from my own hair and then we
had to like fit a wig within a day and
then we the wig wasn't right and we just
had to shoot it we were just like well
we'll
I can't say we made it magical I can't
say we turned something magical out of
it but it's we just it's the kind of
thing that's in the movie and you're
just hoping people will just skip to the
next part I didn't notice there you go
so we're good we're fine anything come
to mind for you oh well many things like
that uh what would be
um it's been a while I have to think
yeah it's a good thing you know our
memory you know it's well done you know
you keep you keep the best you know with
you so
I mean all the extras that did not speak
a single word English and so having to
coordinate a scene like a fight scene a
big Alleyway street with like a hundred
extras and none of them spoke the
language and when we were so particular
on what we wanted in which group we won
where that was the challenge yeah that's
making a film it's okay it's uh there
are a lot of little challenges yeah some
every day every day do you have one
degree
really remember anything that happened
like that but I I remember the the way
that everything was set up is that you
felt that
um you know you were kind of naked in
terms of a metaphorically speaking in
terms of
you know the story that we were telling
and it was it was really interesting
working on that set because there was a
a sense of reality about it because we
were filming and a lot of the places
where these things happened anyway so I
think at one point I just it felt quite
overwhelming to me the fact that we're
filming in a location whereby you know
Nazis had occupied during the second
world war and I just felt really lonely
playing that character
really lonely I felt that he was so
detached from everything his family what
was happening in the war he had this
fantasy relationship with Arena and yet
he his his heart was so disconnected
from everything and I think that that
was his his survival mechanism so that's
my memory of filming this I just felt
really lonely not an easy story to tell
a story that sadly we do desperately
need to keep being reminded of more and
more with every passing day it seems so
thank you for everything you put into
this film to bring it to screen huge
huge huge congratulations to all three
of you to everybody out there Irene AS
Val keep an eye out for it and also for
more interviews coming from Tiff 2023
very soon